nigeria korruption und polizeigewalt
eine generation die sich das nicht mehr
gefallen lassen will der muss schätzchen
zu kriegen einen familienurlaub
sie protestieren gegen eine brutale
polizeieinheit namen stars die größte
waffe dieser jugend social media
der hashtag and saß saß beenden geht
viral und viele promis von beyoncé bis
hillary clinton stellen sich an die
seite von nigerias bevölkerung
[Musik]
und damit kennt zuhauf waren herzlich
willkommen zu dieser folge von trending
diesmal aus dem herzen afrikas in lagos
nigeria größten stadt auf dem ganzen
kontinent
mein name ist marco mohan wird und in
diesem geschäft die frage kann sich die
jugend hier durch social media aktionen
und online aktivismus möglich eine
bessere zukunft kämpfen
ich habe mich auf den weg nach nigeria
gemacht es ist das heimatland meines
vaters wie geht es den nigerianerinnen
und indianern heute etwa ein halbes jahr
nach den aufständen vom flughafen lagos
folglich meine cousine ab wie geht es
dir
mir geht es gut so sie ist richtig gut
aus jung gesund stark ist sich die
pandemie auf den ersten blick sieht man
hier nicht viel von den heftigen
protesten im letzten jahr normales leben
in einer westafrikanischen großstadt hat
sich überhaupt etwas getan
ich stehe jetzt hier vor dem lep iv gelb
hier war im oktober die riesige
demonstration bei der laut amnesty
international
knapp ein dutzend menschen von der
nigerianischen armee niedergeschossen
wurden tausende menschen vor allem junge
leute haben hier tagelang protestiert
gegen ihre korrupten regierung und deren
berüchtigte polizeieinheit namens saß
die spezialeinheit gegen raubüberfälle
aus sicht vieler hier in nigeria eines
schlägertruppe
immer wieder tauchen im netz brutale
videos auf und bringen das fass
schließlich zum überlaufen
vor allem junger nigerianer einen haben
die willkür des staates satt sie sehnen
sich nach einer besseren zukunft nach
mehr freiheit mehr rechte und mehr
chancen
ich treffe die turner um oka nie mehr
ist fotografin hat alles dokumentiert
seine fotos werden auf der ganzen welt
veröffentlicht auch in deutschland wir
fahren jetzt zum neckartal gate wo sich
alles abgespielt hat du siehst sie
reparieren hier gerade alles was von den
menschen zerstört worden ist
sie haben für veränderungen und neue
innovative gekämpft und wollten
sichergehen dass diese generation ihre
stimme erhebt es darf keine
polizeigewalt mehr geben
es gibt ein foto das ich von einem mann
gemacht habe wer genau hinter diesem
blog schutz sucht er hat angst
stell dir vor du siehst einen toten
körper dort liegen
ich hatte angst ganz ehrlich ich hatte
angst ich habe sofort aufgehört fotos zu
machen
dann habe ich zweifel bekommen und mich
gefragt was bringt es hierher zu kommen
mit meiner kamera und zeuge des
geschehens zu werden ohne über die
wahrheit dahinter zu berichten
ich habe noch ein paar bilder gemacht
aber dann aufgehört weil mir mein
eigenes leben in diesem moment wichtiger
war
weißt du kein bild der welt ist es wert
und dafür zu sterben
auch christiana war an dem tag auf der
straße als die masse vor den schüssen
floh wurde sie niedergetrampelt und
verletzt sie ist so traumatisiert dass
sie sich nicht mehr an den ort des
massakers traut ich treffe sie an einer
brücke davor
es wurde immer voller und es waren auf
einmal immer mehr menschen da und dann
ist etwas ganz merkwürdiges passiert
am nachmittag habe ich bemerkt dass die
großen plakatwände die sonst immer
leuchten ausgegangen sind
normalerweise sind die immer aber an dem
tag muss sie jemand ausgemacht haben
wir wussten dass die polizei oder
soldaten zu den protesten kommen
aber was wir niemals geahnt hätten dass
sie uns niederschießen christian als das
ganze gespräch über sichtlich nervös und
immer noch versteht
ich bin geschockt so krass kenne ich
meine zweite heimat lagos nicht viele
demonstrierenden teilen die bilder des
sogenannten lucky massakers im netz sie
gehen um die welt
social media wird zur waffe der jugend
nigerias
nigeria ist ein junges land 60 prozent
der bevölkerung ist unter 24 jahre alt
doch die meisten jungen nigerianischen
menschen fühlen sich ausgebremst und
perspektivlos in einem land das durch
seine ölvorkommen eigentlich reich sein
könnte
sie wollen dass sich endlich etwas tut
gegen korruption und misswirtschaft
[Musik]
die nigerianische musikszene
solidarisiert sich mit der
protestierenden jugend
einer von ihnen ist rem er ist 21 jahre
alt und bereits eine der erfolgreichsten
musiker des kontinents über zwei
millionen menschen folgen ihm auf
instagram auch er hat seine social media
reichweite genutzt um auf besondere art
und weise auf polizeigewalt aufmerksam
zu machen
für mich war das der beste weg eine
botschaft an eine internationale
fangemeinde zu senden
ich habe meine dreadlocks abgeschnitten
und das bild mit einer kurzen nachricht
dazu gepostet ich habe eine große
reichweite über meine plattformen
erfuhren eine menge teilweise
einflussreiche leute davon was in
unserem land gerade passiert auch die
musik war hilfreich um die botschaft
noch weiter zu verbreiten und zu
wiederholen
mit der aktion wendet er sich gegen das
gezielte profiling der sars polizisten
von menschen mit bestimmten frisuren wie
dreadlocks oder teuren outfits ich war
fertig mit einer studio session und dann
wenn ich mit meinem brandneuen auto nach
hause gefahren und auf dem weg nach
hause kam die polizei an sie mal hinten
wo ist das kennzeichen das ist geklaut
das ist nicht registriert und ich meinte
es ist neu
guck ich habe es gerade gekauft hier ich
habe ein foto davon gemacht und sie mal
nein du bist kriminell
dann meinte ich bin remmer und dann
wurde es schlimmer weil dann wussten sie
jackpot er ist ein star
da gibt es geld und dann ging es in die
polizeistation und ich musste da bis
vier uhr morgens bleiben
außerdem sei die polizeieinheit saß
wurde auf druck der proteste aufgelöst
ob das wirklich etwas gebracht hat das
finden wir später raus erst einmal
möchte ich wissen wer ist diese
politisch aktive jugend überhaupt bei
meiner recherche stoß sich auf eine lg
cookie plus freundliche party ich treffe
becky die veranstalterin sie macht sich
stark für ein liberaleres negiert er
nicht viele nigerianische eltern bringen
ihren töchtern bei sich durchzusetzen
es läuft er nach dem motto du bist eine
frau deinen platz ist in der küche woher
hast du dein selbstbewusstsein von
meinem vater er hat mich von klein auf
bestärkt ihre gäste sollen sich hier
heute abend wohl fühlen das ist weg die
besonders wichtig alles okay bei euch
draußen sind stripper und anderer
interessanter kram ich frage mich ob das
hier gefährlich ist haben sie es hier
auf bestimmte leute abgezielt
ja sie sehen es vor allem auf gut
aussehende menschen ab ich habe gehört
dass sie sich auch leute rauspicken von
denen sie denken und dass sie cool sind
oh ja das machen sie jetzt auch weil das
nicht in der bibel steht homosexualität
ist die nigeria offiziell verboten und
wird bis zu 14 jahren haft bestraft je
nach region sogar mit der todesstrafe
[Musik]
warum sind solche veranstaltungen für
die nigerianische jugend wichtig es ist
wichtig weil die jungen menschen wie man
sagt die zukunft sind und solche events
bringen die jungen menschen zusammen und
geben ihnen eine stimme
auf der party bekomme ich den kontakt zu
jemandem der politisch sehr aktiv ist
und mir von seinen eigenen
lebensbedrohlichen erfahrungen erzählen
will
wir treffen uns am nächsten morgen
[Musik]
hallo zusammen mein name ist mad jo
place ich bin ein nicht binär aktivistin
lagers nigeria meine mission ist das
safe spaces zu schaffen
in nigeria haben die saas polizisten
schwule und lesben geprobt und bestraft
und ich haben sie als schwul bezeichnet
und gedroht ins gefängnis zu stecken wo
ich von anderen männern vergewaltigt
werden würde
sie haben gedroht mich umzubringen ohne
dass meine familie davon etwas erfahren
würde
und das alles nur wegen meines aussehens
und das ist nicht nur mir passiert viele
tiere menschen haben online darauf
aufmerksam gemacht wie saas polizisten
ihnen ihre handys wegnehmen und wenn sie
darauf grinder oder chats mit anderen
männern gefunden haben wurden sie dafür
verhaftet
social media ist ein sehr starkes tool
um eine soziale bewegung zu starten
diese bewegung begann online und setzte
sich offline ford damit hat die
veränderungen angefangen seit die
regierung die saas einheiten aufgelöst
hat kann ich nicht nach sicher durch die
stadt bewegen und habe auf dem
nachhauseweg keine angst mehr
vorher war das anders ich hatte angst
vor sars es war der horror
also es ist jetzt schon etwas besser die
urbane mittelschicht in lagos gilt oft
als das gesicht der proteste
doch mehr als 60 prozent der
nigerianische bevölkerung lebt in
extremer armut
gerade hier fehlt jegliche perspektive
und gerade hier ist die wut groß
ich erhalte videonachrichten von canon
europe er ist so was wie eine
leaderfigur in dem armenviertel ag co
denn auch dort gab es endlos proteste
canon will dass mehr leute auch über die
proteste in den gesprächen seine clips
sind schockierend alles kann ich hier
gar nicht zeigen
mitkämpfer abrede ich mich für später
wir werden auch hier einige der opfer
treffen
erstmal möchte ich aber eine andere
perspektive hören ich habe es geschafft
mich mit einem ehemaligen saß polizisten
zu verabreden er möchte anonym bleiben
was man eher zu den anschuldigungen das
war eine einheit um schwere verbrechen
aufzuklären und weißt du kriminelle
mögen es nicht wenn man gegen sie
vorgeht
die saas einheit wurde in den 90ern
gegründet um verbrechen im zusammenhang
mit beispielsweise raub oder in
führungen nachzugehen
doch anstatt die innere sicherheit zu
stärken gerieten sie durch ihre willkür
bei der bevölkerung in verruf ich habe
jetzt mit so vielen angesprochen und die
meisten haben überhaupt nicht das gefühl
dass die polizei sie beschützt was sagst
du dazu
die meisten menschen sind nicht
glücklich wenn sie verhaftet werden ich
werde mir wünschen dass die menschen mit
der nigerianischen polizei kooperieren
denn wir arbeiten ja nicht für uns
selbst wir arbeiten für das land ich
hatte vermutet dass sie erklären würde
was alles schief läuft bei der polizei
in deren struktur doch einsicht es nicht
spürbar
wir diskutieren noch länger seine
haltung in einer mega-city wie lagos mit
hoher kriminalität braucht es eine
polizei die hart durchgreifen aber
unschuldige zu belästigen oder gar zu
töten rechtfertigt das nicht
die fahne gegen die heißt regulär und
diese ziemlich gefährlich sein
sogar also ein kamerateam war selbst
noch nie dort und die haben mir alle
gesagt um hartz iv sätze halten aber bin
der so gekämpft
im grunde genommen wissen egal was uns
erwartet
aber wir müssen dorthin weil dort nach
über einer stunde fahrt kommen wir an
der vierten liga kennen erwartet sich
bereits zu unserem schutz haben wir
einen bewaffneten polizisten dabei das
gefällt ihm allerdings gar nicht wir
diskutieren und entscheiden uns dann
dafür ohne personenschutz ins viertel zu
geben also mit der polizei ist es sogar
noch gefährlicher für die würden mich
dann alles schief angucken und sagen ich
bin ein verräter ein verräter
ja man die polizei ist unser feind und
du kommst hier mit der polizei an kennt
wird uns herum überall armut einige
leute leben hier auf der straße
bist du hier in nigeria sicher du bist
nie sicher wir sollten das nicht sagen
aber ich muss es so sagen
als die menschen hier protestiert haben
hat die polizei in ihnen nur wann dahin
gesehen
die regierungsvertreter haben sie
festgenommen und sie haben sie getötet
krasse eindrücken dieser gegen ich
wusste aber ehrlich gesagt sagen erst
mal dass ich so was gesehen habe
mein vater kommt aus solchen
verhältnissen und ständig in solchen
regeln was muss sich ändern damit leute
nicht mehr in solchen verhältnissen
hineingeboren werden schreibt mir die
kommentare die jungs hier sind super
interessiert wie erregen mit unserem
kamerateam total schnell aufmerksamkeit
ich erfahre von sehr vielen vorfällen
willkürliche polizeigewalt hey du
deutscher ich will meine 7500 euro das
hat mir 7500 euro geklaut die haben mich
verprügelt und weggesperrt
seit diesen scheiß saß leuten ich will
meine kohle zurück
wir treffen hier auch weil er hat bei
den demonstrationen seinen bruder
verloren der schock sitzt tief
der name meines bruders war simon er war
ein herzensguter mensch ein polizist hat
ihn erschossen wo hatte ihn getroffen
am bein sein bein und er hat das nicht
überlebt die leute erzählen mir aber
auch dass es hier tatsächlich ruhiger
geworden ist nach den protesten im
oktober
hat dieser ganze online aktivismus und
dieses benutzen der hashtags irgendwas
gebracht hat dass deine situation
verbessert tatsächlich ja hätte es das
nicht gegeben würde niemand wissen was
hier in nigeria los ist geht es um viel
mehr als nur um polizeigewalt
weißt du die hashtags füllen unsere
bräuche an django lee ist eines der
grössten ghettos in der welt dieser mann
ist aus ghana welche gehört zu den ihr
über dieses delta verstehst du wenn man
hier mehr in bildung investieren würde
würde hier alles besser werden in den
60ern lief das besser als jetzt
das wirkt wir sind sehr wohlhabender
kampf oder du hast absolut recht und
sechs monate später gibt es hier für die
leute keinerlei entschädigung
ich kann es dir zeigen es gibt hier so
viele menschen die sind gestorben hier
in angola haben die irgend eine
entschädigung bekommen
kann man das überhaupt entschädigen dass
leute getötet werden dass man seine
angehörige verliert selbst wenn jemand
kriminell war ist das absolut keine
lösung
also es ist nicht unbedingt einen kampf
gegen die polizei sondern vielleicht
gegen mächtigere schichten gegen die
eliten ja ich rede noch lange mit canon
er will weiter protestieren und nicht
nachgeben er weiß aber auch wenn sich
nichts ändert bleibt ihm nur das land zu
verlassen
seine familie hat er bereits nach
kamerun geschickt nigeria hat eine menge
probleme zu bewältigen aber es gibt hier
auch so viele entschlossene menschen die
wirklich etwas bewirken und das lässt
mich hoffen aber das hashtag aktionen
alleine nicht reichen um tief
verwurzelte strukturelle ungleichheit
und unterdrückung zu bekämpfen ist auch
klar wie sieht ihr das ganze bringen
welche aktionen wie nie zu
blacklight mehr der angriff vom kreis
sind kein schaden
oder wie wir hat das alles einen sinn
ist social media aktivismus genug macht
man das eigene gute gewissen ich will es
wissen
ich schreibe es in die kommentare
ansonsten künftig noch andere folgen
ständigen abonniert den kanal und
visiert von anders wieder